[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم
هجوم يستهدف مديريه الامن في انقره ووزير
الداخليه التركيه يقول ان مهاجما فجر نفسه
بينما حيجد مهاجم اخر واصيب شرطيا وقال
رئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان خلال افتتاح
الدوره الجديده للبرلمان ان تركيا ستقضي
على اخر ارهابي داخل حدودها وخارجها مئات
المستوطنين اليهود يقتحمون باحات المسجد
الاقصى في ثاني ايام عيد العرش اليهودي
وسط حراسه المشدده وقوات كبيره من شرطه
الاحتلال فرضت قيودا على دخول المصلين
الفلسطينيين الى الاقصى كما ضيقت على طلبه
المدارس داخله ومنعت عددا منهم من الدخول
لندن تدرس خطه لنشر قوات التدريب
البريطانيه مستقله عن النيتو في اوكرانيا
وروسيا تؤكد ان المدربين البريطانيين
سيتحولون الى اهداف مشروعه عند وصولهم الى
كييف وتتهم الغربه بدفعها بقوه نحو حرب
عالميه ثالثه
وزاره الماليه السعوديه تعلن البيان
التمهيديه لميزانيه عام
2024 وسط توقعات بان يبلغ اجمالي
الايرادات للعام المقبل نحو 312 مليار
دولار بينما قدرت الوزاره ان يبلغ اجمالي
النفقات اكثر من 300 وثلاثه وثلاثين مليار
وهي الاعلى على الاطلاق الى اللقاء